well you can't talk about the history of
whippin HS without talking about the
incredible accomplishments of the
Polgara sisters no question I mean they
had an outsized contribution to women in
chess and when I think about the Polgara
somehow I kind of grew up with them it
was like there was there was Susan there
was Judith there was Sophia and it
wasn't just that they were breaking
records they were destroying the records
that had previously existed and I think
that the oldest Susan was really a
trailblazer for the pole guards for
Judith and for Sophia that she really
could carry the sins and you know just
force open the doors and I remember that
I was thinking to myself how fantastic
it was that there's the three sisters
who were playing really well and we're
doing all of these wonderful things and
it felt like the Hungarian Chess
Federation behaved as if they were
cursed to have these girls I'd like
where to put should they be allowed in
the male championship should they be
allowed on the open Olympiad teams and
it was like the Hungarian chess
federation the Communist Party just
seemed to hate the girls that they
really had a lot of difficulties in
their chest careers yeah and you know
there were so much resistance I was a
huge admirer of them coming out
particularly Judith's games I would try
to really you know emulate the openings
she play exactly billions like I love
seeing her game the attacks and the
tactics but I noticed like a lot of the
commentary would just like focus on the
fact that they train so hard that was
like you know they're not talented they
just study all the time
it didn't really make any sense because
of course anybody who reached that level
trained hard right and a lot of people
were trying to point them out as
exceptions to the rule right there is in
reality what they proved is that anybody
with hard work and well obviously that's
another debate I'm sure very you need
some talent as well too especially to
reach the 2700 heights that Judah did
but it really showed that if you treat
girls the same way that you treat boy is
is somebody who has unlimited
intellectual capacity if they have the
passion and the drive then the sky's the
limit
and that's what Laszlo did that both
parents indeed and then there was also
this idea that you know like they were
tainted night they were autistic or
something they would just somehow they
had this chest bug genetic Eugene and in
truth they were all like born polygons
Hungarian Russian English they just took
languages and they were really smart and
they were funny and they were engaging
and they were all of the press that they
were getting all of the criticisms that
they were getting the moment you sat
down and at a three-minute conversation
you just had to complete really rewire
whatever image you had because it was
wrong it was just absolutely wrong and
for me especially even though Susan was
extraordinarily strong and came into
world's top 100 it was actually the
youngest Judith that got into the top 10
became a candidates world champion ship
player and there the question was well
like Judith as well as the pole guards
themselves they issued female events
they wanted to play against male players
male competitors it was only I'm trying
to remember but I think it was Tesla
Nike 1988 that for the first time they
played all together on the Hungarian
team in the Olympiad yeah that's right I
think dude it was about 12 years old at
the time and right she was just
scorching people left and right there
was exactly there was one little
miniature she played in that tournament
that I just showed to the girl
at the the scouting merit badge
competition where she please
he takes FA Bishop eight-six rookie
ain't made i'm just really just stunning
an inspiring play from judah which like
so many generations of girls grow up
looking at her games and being inspired
by her right and now of course we have
Susan Polgar in st. Louis area with
Webster University right and many times
national champion there yeah and so it's
it's it's party history but it's not
just history they're also continuing to
make history jutted is retired from
competition but she's involved in so
many projects as well exactly
and I it's just one of the great stories
of chasse about how you know if you have
enough support from your parents you can
ignore the other obstacles in your way
like you mentioned the Federation and
the Hungarian Chess Federation and just
the expectation that women couldn't be
as good as bad right the middle sister
Sophia she was kind of Miss place so to
speak but what a lot of people don't
realize about Sophia is that she had one
of the greatest TP ours I mean
tournament performance rating of all
times she played an amazing like night
at half out of 11 or something like that
I think yeah close to a 3,000 result and
you know like when you think about all
of the pole guards and all of the great
performances that they had that was
probably one of the best ever I think
I've seen interviews where Susan claims
that Sophia was actually the most
talented yeah in some ways and she
became an artist as well so you know
just a really incredible story and
family I know of course that Sofia
married and moved to Israel the Yona and
her husband doctor and it was like oh
you know she didn't pursue her chest
career not in the way in fashion that
Judith really I want to say dedicated
herself I mean you'd have really worked
hard on her
she did and you have a story that you
sometimes tell in our broadcasts about
Judit being garry kasparov for the first
time as that was a momentous thing in
chess history yes we still haven't had a
female who's won the world championship
but we do have a female who beat the
world champion and we have a female who
beat the number I guess Gary was she
when she beat she beat Gary and she also
beat Magnus Carlsen right in a
tournament so she she's beat all the top
players in the world exactly and the
story was of course in 2002 it was USSR
you're Russia it was Russia versus the
rest of the world and I was actually the
team captain for the rest of the world
team and you would play these rapid
games for rapid games over four days and
so on and I took Judith out of the
lineup oh she was so angry at me she was
and I said Judith and I don't want you
to come to the game Judith but I want
you to work with Victor the Viktor
Korchnoi and just prepare yourself bring
as much energy as you can for your game
with Garry Kasparov she was like so mad
so mad and she destroyed him she
absolutely crushed him and I was
standing right behind her at the time
that Garry resigned they shook hands she
stood up she turned around and she
jumped into my arms and I'm holding her
like this and she's looking directly at
me and she's goes I'm back in business
right you know absolutely and wow talk
about a competitor yes well thank I mean
thank you for that making that
contribution to the Women's World Chess
Championships I mean not to women in
chess
yeah I mean of course it was Judith who
gets the credit you get a little bit of
credit for making that victor worked
hard and you did it all oh my goodness
it was it was a thrill just to be a part
of that history and by the way we were
playing in Moscow and we won
he beat the Russians but it was a Russia
versus the rest of the world the most
subdued quiet closing ceremony ever
but very enthusiastic about our victory
Judith got a lot of applause I bet you
did I bet you did it's funny that since
then Garry Kasparov's been pretty pretty
active in promoting girls and women in
chess his namesake foundation the
Kasparov chess foundation actually runs
this wildly successful event in
conjunction with the u.s. chess and
Renaissance chess late with all girls
Nationals in Chicago each year right so
that's like one of the big trademark
Garry events and I think it actually
started around 2002 pretty and it's been
around for about 15 years now so maybe a
few years later yeah but it's funny
perhaps that that victory he was like
you get a confirmation there